Brasil ha regresado al escenario mundial
después de una inexplicable ausencia lo
ha dicho Lula En referencia al mandato
aislacionista de bolsonario lo he dicho
en China que a su vez también vuelve de
una esencia en su caso por la política
de Cero covid y tras esos paréntesis
diplomáticos Brasil y China se necesitan
no solo por sus economías
complementarias sino por su visión
compartida de un mundo multipolar ha
repetido Lula que no participará en
ninguna guerra fría pero el contraste
con su predecesor bolsonaro un ferviente
anticomunistas demasiado grande como
para no inquietar a Estados Unidos Lula
ha defendido el papel de china en la
globalización ha apoyado el alto el
fuego de su plan de paz para Ucrania y
acordado con Pekín evitar el dólar en
sus intercambios comerciales el primer
día de Lula en Shanghai tampoco habrá
tranquilizado a Estados Unidos ha
visitado la sede del nuevo banco del
desarrollo es el brazo financiero de los
brics o las economías emergentes y que
nació como alternativa al Banco Mundial
o el fondo monetario internacional
tradicionalmente dominados por occidente
también ha visitado un laboratorio de
Huawei la tecnológica china que acumula
sanciones de Washington por
presuntamente
amenazar a la seguridad nacional Lula
mañana se reunirá con el presidente
chino en Pekín donde hablarán del plan
de paz para Ucrania y es previsible que
le den otro empujón a los brics un grupo
del que ambos son entusiastas